♪♪
I’m aware of the dangers out
there.
And I know you’re scared.
(Alien screeches)
But I can’t hide and wait
(Gun shots)
for the world to end.
So this is it.
(Gun shots)
Do we fight
or let go?
(Explosion)
♪♪
We’re really in the thick of the
war
and the aliens have a
stronger foothold on Earth.
It’s a story about a collective,
surviving a moment of complete
chaos.
For months now we’ve been
outnumbered, outflanked,
outgunned.
There’s only one person who’s
ever made contact.
You.
These aliens come at you even
harder.
They tap into your weakness.
They’ve managed to really get
into your head.
Are you sure you want to do
this?
(Breathing heavy)
(Alien chittering)
They have evolved. They are now
more vicious, more aggressive.
Run. Now.
(Screams)
They are expanding.
There’s still discovery, there’s
still questions.
What is going on and why it’s
happening.
The answers are here.
♪♪
It’s not only a story about
an invasion of aliens,
it’s about
the human connection.
This family is my whole world.
I will do anything and
everything to hold it together.
And we’re all on a mission...
I just can’t see the pattern.
...to understand how to save
humanity.
♪♪
If Season 1 was the quiet before
the storm,
Season 2 is the storm.
♪♪
Showtime.
(Scream)
Sarah!
♪♪